[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANU BATRA: Good afternoon.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Today, we'll be
covering Anthos Storage
and how it enabled seamless
data management for Kubernetes.
We'll start with a quick
set of introductions.
My name is Manu Batra.
I'm the Product Manager
for Anthos Storage
for Google Cloud.
Here with me is Oleksiy.
He's part of the engineering
team for Anthos Storage.
And we also have representation
from our partner team,
Robin.io.
And Partha will be covering
some use cases around
how Anthos Storage is helping
customers around seamless data
management.
From the topic's perspective,
the areas we want to focus on
is what really is
Anthos Storage.
What are the key use
cases, key functionalities?
It is delivering,
getting into why
we think it's a worthy
challenge to be addressed,
what are the challenges
today with managing
stateful workloads, and how
we are enabling with partner
ecosystems.
So, a list of what are our
partners we are working with
and how we are enabling,
not just internal,
but externally, how we
are meeting customers
where they are with
the storage providers
they are working with.
We'll get a deep dive into
the architectural pieces,
getting into what are
all the moving parts,
how are they connected.
And eventually, the
most exciting part
is going to be a demo
where you'll actually
be able to see a
couple of use cases
around how we take snapshots
and backups and roll back.
So that's a pretty
packed agenda.
We'll get started on this.
So starting with what--
what is Anthos Storage?
The key goal we're delivering
with Anthos Storage
is we're providing
enterprise-grade storage
management functions
for GKE workloads,
whether those workloads
are running on-prem
or in the cloud.
The goal is to be able to extend
the consistent experience,
the centralized control,
agility, and flexibility
that Anthos brings to the
table to the storage layer.
And to do that, we're
working essentially--
our goal is to provide
customers with a consistent set
of control plane
interfaces where,
independent of the vendor that
they're using for the data
plane, we want to provide a
set of APIs and interfaces
which are consistent.
And to enable
that, we're working
with the community and our
partner community also,
so a set of partners
we're working
can say how do we
engage and enroll them
to get that interface
adopted much more widely.
So, it's a much
more broader effort
integrating with
community and the partners
and providing customers with a
seamless, consistent experience
for stateful
workload management.
Now, getting into a
bit more specifics
about what are
the key use cases,
the key functionality sets
we are planning to deliver,
the first set of
functionality is
to enable stateful workloads.
What we really look for is, if
I have to do storage management
functions, especially
enterprise-grade storage
management functions
like snapshots,
can I do it in
the same interface
that I am managing
my application?
Or for those
functions, do I have
to go outside and enable those?
The goal for us is to
enable those functions
in the same interface,
the same place where
you are managing other
application-level functions.
Other pieces we're
looking for here is--
well, if you're running
enterprise applications,
especially stateful
how do you manage
disaster recovery
for those applications?
Can I take backups?
And what even backups
means in that world,
is the code, data,
and all together,
or it's just parts and
pieces at different rates.
So one of the key goals is
to enable backups in GCS.
And then you can rehydrate
them either on-prem
or in the cloud,
wherever you prefer
is the right place for the
workload in the application.
Moving on, with any
stateful application,
one of the challenging
parts is upgrades.
How do we enable
upgrades, and what happens
before you take an upgrade?
So being able to
enable local snapshots
of a stateful application--
that's another
set of functionality.
And then, of course, security
and role-based access
is key to any
enterprise-grade application
or be ready for even enterprise
applications to come on board.
Diving a bit more deeper,
so if you look at GCP,
how we enable data
protection on GCP is you
can take a snapshot in
a multi-regional bucket
or a regional bucket in
GCS, which protects us
against either
regional failures,
total failures across.
Now, the goal is to work
with the partner community
so that the backups
can be stored in GCS.
And depending on
the data locality
that the customer service
levels and the compliance pieces
allow, you will be able to
store those backups anywhere
in GCS, either a
regional a multi-regional
or a specific bucket bit on.
So it's a close collaboration
with the partners
and the cloud to
enable the backup
and restore functionality.
Now getting a bit
around why we started
to solve this problem
and some some of the data
points we wanted to share as
we're talking to more customers
and partners.
So, with the evolution
of Kubernetes,
we've gone from a
beginner-enthusiast phase
into Enterprise 1.0 and
moving towards a 2.0 adoption
where customers are
looking at Kubernetes
not just for stateless, but
also for stateful workload.
And part of the
reason is they are
looking for, can I have
a consistent experience
and a standardized platform
for all my applications,
versus some different
architectures
for different applications.
And it's a move towards
that consistency
and being able to take the
advantage of Kubernetes
extend to stateful applications.
But, again, as we get into it,
some of the basic functions
like key management,
app-consistent snapshots,
being able to take
cluster management-- those
are key areas that have to
be addressed consistently
across before we get to that.
And as we move on, we're
looking to add functionality
around observability.
If I have an SLO violation,
how soon can I address that?
Can I find all the moving
parts and pin them down
to say where is the choke
point, or how do I address that
within a reasonable time frame?
And last but not
least is getting
into how do we enable
management at scale
with a rich set of UIs.
Couple of more data points.
Now, there was a Google survey
done before GKE customers.
Ended up a lot of
customers, around 39%,
are looking for a standard
lift-and-shift of applications.
But if you look at
the numbers, there
is a larger set of
customers, close to 59%, that
are looking to modernize
the applications on-prem
and then move to the
cloud as and when
they become ready, versus
kind of just moving
that in the cloud and using
it as infrastructure pieces.
So, our goal for
the Anthos Storage
is to address that
need where customers
are looking to
modernize applications
on-prem before they move to
the cloud and start scaling
or actually doing migrations,
whatever the use case may be.
Now going deeper into what
are the specific challenges
that we see today with
stateful workloads.
And one of the key challenges
we see is, for the most part,
the storage that exists
today is designed
to be mapped to a host.
And when you get into
Kubernetes world,
it's containers
and applications.
So bridging that gap
has been a challenge.
So that's where we're
working with the partners
to help enable bridge
that gap in a much
more standardized way.
Next piece is, according
to a survey that
was done by Datadog last year,
the biggest difference is also
the average lifespan
of a container.
An average lifespan
of a container
is two days, versus for
the VM, it's 23 days.
Now, in that excel,
the data point
is interesting
with what it means.
What it means is that, can I
move my data at the same pace
that my application is moving?
Can I match that pace?
And if I don't, what
risk does it create?
Do I have the backups?
Do I have the restore
points that if something
goes wrong during that mobility,
because it is so agile,
can I restore my application
back in a consistent state?
So that's kind of
a key take away
from how we are
interpreting that statement.
Now getting into basic
data lifecycle management,
can I create
app-consistent snapshots
when I'm running a DB inside?
What does it mean to take
an app-consistent snapshot?
Does it mean I take a
snapshot of the data?
And if there is a
separate change,
do you take a snapshot
of code and config?
Or can I take a
consistent entity
with code, config, and
data, and make a snapshot
so when I take a snapshot
and I relocate it,
I am assured that I can
rehydrate my application
and no components
are left behind?
So, these are some of
the issues we really
are seeing more and
more common as customers
are trying stateful applications
with Kubernetes GKE.
Now getting a bit
deeper around what's
our approach to solve this
and how we're solving this.
We understand storage
is very personal to what
workloads you're working on.
This also depends on what
partners you choose to work on
given your workloads.
So our intent is
to meet you where
you're comfortable
with the vendors
that you're comfortable
working with.
With that spirit, we're working
with a large set of vendors.
And listed here are some--
an initial set of storage
technology partners
that we already
started working with
and we're engaging to
solve those use cases.
But this list will
grow over time.
And our goal is to really
meet with the vendors--
with the partners that
you're comfortable with which
match the workload that
are deployed with the SLAs
that you need for that
particular workload.
So as you bring the
partners on board,
really we also want to
create a level of comfort
by creating a
certification process.
And we're looking essentially
at four different types
of certifications
or validations.
One could be-- what
we're developing
is an open interface,
and partners
are welcome to write
to that interface.
But once they write,
they can self qualify it,
and they can distribute
it to their channels.
The next phase is that we, as
Google, test those drivers,
those softwares
in our lab to make
sure they work well
with Anthos environment
and things work seamlessly.
And at that point, they
get a choice to say,
should we distribute
those through the vendor
infrastructure, or
should we distribute
those specifically like
software-defined vendors,
and also drivers for
appliance vendors?
Should we redistribute
them through Marketplace,
which gives customers a lot more
seamless, unified experience?
Eventually, as the
program matures,
we really want to
get to a point where
we are pre-packaging certain
sets of drivers in the bundle.
So that gives one less click or
one less step for the customers
and the experience is
a lot more seamless.
With this, I'll invite
Partha on the stage
to talk more about some of the
customer challenges and use
cases.
PARTHA SEETALA: Thank you, Manu.
So before I get started, let
me just see a show of hands.
How many of you are
running stateful workloads
on containers today,
or Kubernetes today?
It's very impressive, actually.
If you think about
it, just last year
I would say that very few
people [INAUDIBLE] their hands.
And this is actually
an ongoing trend.
Anyway, with that,
so who am I, and what
am I talking about today,
and what am I doing here?
So as a way of introduction,
my name is Partha Seetala.
And I'm the Co-founder
and CTO of Robin.io,
and we are partners with
Google on Anthos platform.
Now, a little bit
about the company.
So the mission of
the company was
to enable our customers to
run mission-critical stateful
workloads on containers, and
by extension, Kubernetes.
So when I say stateful
workloads, what does it mean?
I mean, it could be just
a small Jenkins job,
but persistent
volumes underneath it.
But when we look at the market,
the real pain, if you will,
was around the more complex
platforms such as the big data
platforms that are Cloudera,
Elasticsearch, Splunk,
or of course, the NoSQL
platforms such as Mongo
and Cassandra and Couch,
and even traditional RDBMS
solutions like Postgres, Oracle
RAC, Con, and all that, right?
And it's kind of surprising.
If we look at it, nobody
really associates the word
"Oracle RAC" with Kubernetes.
But we have production
deployments of that.
So I think it's
safe to say that we
know a thing or two about how
you can run these applications
on Kubernetes and what
are the real challenges
that somebody is going to see
when you actually manage them.
The one point I do
want to highlight
is based on the experience
of the type of workloads
that we have been able
to onboard on Kubernetes.
We have brought the expertise of
how you take all of this stuff
and then package it
into a set of APIs
that you could alert with
Google to give to the community.
And our hope here
is that this would
become like what SQL
did to structured query,
this would do to data
management on Kubernetes
for stateful apps.
And that is the
thing that we want.
And this API sets
to be something
that a lot of other
partners will also embrace.
But what you're
going to see today
is the API specs and the
demo of how it looks like.
But before we go there, what
is so different about running
stateful workloads?
So why do you even have to talk
about this as a main topic,
right?
So, a couple of things here.
So unlike a stateless workload,
which is very ephemeral
and the way you scale
it is very different
than, let's say, a
database where you just
don't add more parts
and take them away
because they are cost-associated
with data redistributions
and all that.
So, that's on the
deployment side.
But once deployed, unlike
a stateless application,
a stateful one has
a very long life.
And people are used to doing
data management on that.
And when I say data
management, it's
usually around data
protection, whether it
is snapshots or backups or it
is around data collaborations
along with their apps-- things
like clones and all that,
right?
But for the folks
in the room who
have come from the
storage background,
these are not new terms.
I mean, everybody
understands these things.
But the world is
very different today.
In the previous world,
all these things
were usually done by the
storage administrator.
In today's world, in
the Kubernetes world,
it's done by
developers and devops,
and they are not
necessarily storage experts.
And it's very hard
for them to comprehend
what it means to
go snapshot a LUN
and what it means to
go and clone it, right?
So what you really need to do is
elevate this entire experience
into an application construct so
that developers can go and say,
I have a Mongo that I've spun
up either through an operator
or through Helm.
And I want to do a snapshot it.
I don't want to back it up.
I don't want to boot it from
one data center to the other.
Now I'm going to go a
little deeper into what
it means to do those things.
And so I'm going to use a
few of our real-life customer
experiences and pains
the customer the had
and how we had solved them.
So the first thing is
our own data protection.
So, you want to basically keep
a copy of your application
and its data in such a way
that if there is a corruption,
you can easily roll back to a
more cleaner, pristine state.
Now, there are
two ways to do it.
And it's really important to
kind of capture both of them
and talk about the differences.
There's this notion of
snapshots, which is usually
a vein which you can snapshot
your entire application
on the same disk from which
it is storing all the data.
And then there is a
thing called backup,
where you basically
take these snapshots
and then move it
up into the cloud.
So both of them solve two
different needs, right?
However, if you look
at today's challenges,
the way you would do this--
let's say you're running--
I'll just take a very
simple example, Postgres.
If you're doing
Postgres today, you
would have to go and tell your
storage administrator that,
hey, listen, I want a
snapshot of my storage LUNs.
They would snapshot that.
But then what?
We just have a snapshotted LUN.
What the developer
would want to do is they
would want to go and snapshot
not just the storage volumes,
but all the material around
that storage volume, which
would be obviously the PVCs,
then things like ConfigMaps,
then StatefulSets, services,
secrets, all of that.
Because all of that essentially
forms your application.
And once you can capture that
as an application snapshot,
then you can enable workflows
such as creating a quick clone
or migrating it to a different
data center and things
like that, right?
The next one is around clones,
so maybe a use case from one
of our Oracle RAC customers.
So it's a large towels
bookings company.
They run Oracle RAC
as a service on ROBIN.
And one of the use case that
they have is their DBAs--
at the end of every quarter,
they have to run reports.
And they don't want to
go and run those reports
on the production database.
So what do they do?
They go to this
platform and they say,
I want to create a
very quick clone.
And they create a clone
that's not-- again, as I said,
it's not a storage clone.
It is a fully
functional, running,
Oracle RAC instance
with the data
as of a previous
snapshot that was taken.
Another use case
for a clone would
be to validate
patches and upgrades.
Nobody wants to go and
run a patch or an upgrade
on the production database.
Either you like to create a
clone, run it there, validate.
If everything is fine, then you
would go and apply it, right?
So those are the
kind of use cases
that you can enable
and make it much more
easy to consume in this
world of Kubernetes
by elevating the entire
experience to applications.
And the last
interesting use case
that I would like to
capture is app portability.
And what I mean by
that is more and more
you'll see that developers want
to liberate their applications
and data from the underlying
infrastructure choices.
You might start
today on-premises.
Let's say all in AWS.
But you would like to go migrate
tomorrow into Google Cloud
because you have resources there
that you really want to use.
Maybe you want to use
TPUs there, right?
So you want to have the
ability to go and migrate
your entire application, not
just the storage volumes.
That's incredibly difficult
because each data center,
each cloud, has a different
way in which it does storage
and networking and all that.
So you could abstract
it out in such a way
that you can very
easily migrate things.
Now, so, with this--
I mean, these are the
kind of experiences
that we have been able to give
to our customers on Kubernetes.
And this is the experience
that we have shared
and we code all of these APIs
with a very deep integration
with the Anthos Storage team.
So what does it mean?
How would a partner's
life look like once we
have embraced these API sets?
So, I'm going to show you
what we have done at ROBIN.
So let's look at this on
the left-hand side, before--
today, maybe, right?
Or you hear what is-- or what
I'm going to say on the right.
The way you deploy your
stateful workload is either you
would use the standard Kube
portal interface and use YAML,
or you will use a Helm
chart to deploy it,
or you might use an operator
if one exists, right?
So there is nothing different.
This is a very standard
way of doing things.
But this is just provisioning.
What you need beyond this would
be something like this, right?
There you can go and
do an entire snapshot
of your Postgres, let's
say, Helm release, right,
or in running instance
of your operator.
Or you can clone it.
You can push it from
on-premises to GCS, right?
And then from GCS, you will
be able to drain it back
into a different region.
So think of all
the power of this.
GCS is an object store.
Postgres sits on a block store.
So what do you mean?
What we are doing here is from
one data center or one region,
you're taking a snapshot.
You're pushing that
snapshot from block.
The snapshot sits on block.
You push that
snapshot from block
into GCS, which is object.
And you can go to a
completely different region.
And using GCS's global
distribution of objects,
you can go to a completely
different region
and rehydrate this data
from object into block
and offer it as a
running application.
Now, imagine the
power of this, right?
So that is what this
API set is going to do.
And we're hoping that
this does truly become
the SQL of data management.
And we are very
honored to be a part
of this effort with Google.
With that, I'll hand it off to
Oleksiy for showing you a demo
and going into the
technical details.
OLEKSIY STASHOK:
Thank you, Partha.
Hello.
My name is Oleksiy Stashok.
I'm a Software Engineer
in Anthos Storage team.
And yeah, I'm
going to just stay.
I think I have a mic.
PARTHA SEETALA: There you go.
OLEKSIY STASHOK: OK.
So let's take a look
at the architecture
and the high-level architecture.
So here, you can see
that we introduced
a couple of new components
to Kubernetes stage.
And every component
is represented
by this red block, which
is a component controller.
And the arrows pointing
towards the block
represent API for
the controller.
The APIs are defined as
Kubernetes custom resource
definitions, CRDs.
And you can notice that these
components are nicely layered
one on top of the other.
And so the top can
leverage functionality
of the component on the bottom.
So, let's take a look at
the individual components.
So, the volume group
controller and API
is responsible for taking
crash-consistent volume group
snapshots and backups.
It talks to CSI driver to run
some storage-level commands
like take a snapshot,
create a backup,
restore a volume from
a snapshot or backup.
And it uses the GCS--
it uses GCS to
export the backups.
So, the next component is
application controller and API.
And application
controller and API
are responsible for
taking application-level,
application-consistent
snapshots and backups, which
include both persistent data
and application metadata.
And we use an application backup
management service to keep--
as a global register
for our backups.
So the backups could be used
across different Kubernetes
clusters.
And the third component is
application policy controller
and API, which is responsible
for scheduling and retention,
application-level snapshots and
backups, given some policies.
OK, at this point, I wanted
to just step back and explain
how we model our APIs,
what is the API structure,
and what's the responsibility
of each piece of the API.
So we model our API the same
way as Kubernetes models
persistent volumes and
persistent volume snapshots,
which means we use a controller,
claim, and content triplets.
And their class provides
portability across clusters.
And it refers to the specific
controller or handler
to handle claims.
And it also contains some
configuration for controllers--
say, some secret
keys or something
like opaque parameters
for controllers.
And class usually is provided
by Kubernetes administrators.
The next one is a claim,
which is provided by a user.
And actually, it's a request for
action, like take a snapshot,
create a backup.
And the content is
the actual result
of the controller
processing the claim,
so, like, snapshot was taken.
Here is a snapshot ID.
OK, so in this
demo, we're mostly
talking about
application component.
And now we are
going to actually--
I'm going to just explain
the component's API and CRDs
we use in this component.
So, first one is
stateful application,
which defines an
application which
has some persistent state.
You can use this CRD when
you want to just refer
to your existing application.
And later, you can refer
to the stateful application
when you take
snapshot or backup.
Or you can create
stateful application
and refer to existing snapshot
or backup in order to control--
to actually provision
you an application
based on the
snapshot and backup.
The next one's
application snapshot,
which represent the
like state stored in
the local storage.
And when we say "state," means
it's both persistent data
plus metadata.
This here, it can be
used in two cases--
when you want to
actually snapshot
existing application
in your cluster,
or if you want to
import external backup
to the local storage.
Application backup-- it
represents the application
state stored in external
storage, like in GCS,
for example.
Again, here, we are
talking about state
which is represented by both
persistent data plus metadata.
And application backups
are used either to back up
a running application
or in order
to export the local snapshot
to external storage.
Application rollback defines a
user request to just rollback
existing application
to a previously taken
snapshot or backup.
OK, here comes the demo.
Go back to slides.
Thank you.
So, I just wanted to touch
upon the use cases which
I'm going to cover in the demo.
So, first use case is
rollback an application
after unsuccessful upgrade.
And the second one,
we're going to migrate
the stateful workload from
on-premise Kubernetes cluster
to the cloud Kubernetes cluster,
which is, in our case, GKE.
The demo setup.
So we actually have two
Kubernetes clusters.
One is running on-prem
by GKE On-Prem.
And we run it on VMware
and use the ROBIN
as the software-defined storage.
In the cloud, we use GKE as a
provider of Kubernetes cluster.
And we also use ROBIN
software-defined storage
for running on top
of persistent disks.
Our application consists
of two components,
is the UI, which
for simplicity we
represent as just simple
SQLPad application, which
is just a web-based SQL tool.
And persistent state is
stored in Postgres, which
we run in master-slave mode.
And just to maybe add you some
color about the application,
so let's assume this is
a sales application we
run for our company's sales.
But for the purpose
of the demo, we'll
only take a look at the part
of the application which
is responsible for
handling customers.
OK, with that, we can
switch to the console.
Thank you.
OK, so now, the
console where we--
the console on-prem, which you
can tell by this little blue
arrow at the bottom--
I will switch from the
on-prem to the cloud
when we need it for
the second use case.
I prepared a set of
scripts, batch scripts.
Mostly, they are only like--
it's just they wrap a
cube couple commands.
So before running
every script, I'm
going to show its content
so we are on the same page
and explain what does
it do, what it does.
And yeah, so let's take a look
at the application which is
running in the on-prem cluster.
So, we see, as I mentioned,
it's a sales application
which consists of two parts.
The first one is the
component of Postgres
running in master-slave mode,
and the actual UI we have here.
So let's take a look at
the UI and the content
and the data we have
in the database.
So, we have a customers
table, which has--
for every customer, we have
first name, last name, email,
and company.
So, let's run some
prerequisites.
First, prerequisite script.
But let me show you what it has.
In this script, we just deploy
ApplicationSnapshotClass
and ApplicationBackupClass.
In the snapshot class,
we define that ROBIN is
going to handle the snapshots.
And we say that--
and here, we defined also
Postgres quiesce and unquiesce
hooks.
So we are able to take
application-consistent
snapshots.
In the backup class, we defined
just the backup handler who's
going to handle our backups.
OK, let's run the script.
So, the next step would be--
we have a running application.
Now let's create a stateful
application on top of it.
So we are going to run
the second script where we
defined a stateful application.
And we refer to the
sales application
which we are currently running.
So now we're going
to wait a little bit
until controller sees that
request and fulfills it.
OK, so we registered a stateful
application of the controller.
OK, so now it's time
for the first use case.
It's a rollback after
unsuccessful upgrade.
Yeah, so, here is a story.
Assume you have PM come
in, approaching you.
Like, PM-- let's just say, like,
Manu asked me to specifically
say it's not him.
So it's not Manu.
Yeah, so, we are
on the same page.
Yeah, so, where was I?
Yeah, so, Manu approaches
me and says, OK,
so sales team has
new requirements.
And they want actually
to extend the way
we maintain the company's data.
So now we have company name
only as part of the customer,
but they want to actually
extend that functionality
and maintain more information
about the company.
And I said, yeah, that's cool.
I need three days for that.
He says, nice.
You have one day.
I got to go.
Bye.
OK.
Now we have one day to
actually do two changes, right?
We need to change
the UI and we need
to actually provide the
change to the database schema.
So we can extract the info
from the customers table--
we need to extract the
information of company
and put that into
a separate table.
OK, so I prepared an
upgrade script for that.
But considering it
didn't have much time
for testing and it's usually--
it's, like, database
schema change is usually
pretty dangerous.
So we are going to
take a snapshot first
of the existing application.
Now let me show you what we do.
So, we are creating an
application snapshot
and refer to the application--
the stateful application
which we are currently
running, which we registered
in the previous step.
OK, so, controller
started working on it.
So just to stress it,
so when we say, like,
take an application snapshot
and take an application backup,
we are talking about both
persistent data and metadata.
OK, snapshot is ready.
Everything is ready
for the upgrade.
So let's do the upgrade.
OK, this is our current
state of the application.
As you see, we use
UI version 1.0.
And we're going to
upgrade it to version 2.0.
And here is the rest
of the application.
So we are ready to continue.
Here is the script, which will
perform the actual database
upgrade--
schema upgrade.
So, are you sure?
Yes, I am.
Got to just wait
for the upgrade.
It's going to be really soon.
Done.
OK.
So now, please notice that we
have UI version 2.0 running.
And let's give some
time for the application
to settle down so it's still,
like, UI's terminating.
Come on, come on, come on.
Yeah.
OK.
So upgrade-- I would say
it was successful, right?
No error.
Let's take a look at the data.
Right, you can see that now
we have three tables, not only
one.
So let's take a look
at the company's table.
Right, so company
names were successfully
transferred from the customer's
table to the new table.
Let's take a look the customers.
OK, yeah, please
notice what happened.
Instead of-- like,
during the upgrade,
instead of extracting
the company
and then deleting this
column, I actually
deleted the email
column from the table.
But fortunately, we have
our snapshot, right?
So now we are able to
rollback our application
to the previous state,
fix the upgrade script,
and run it again.
So now let's rollback
the application.
So I'm going to run this script,
which defines the rollback--
points to the sales
stateful application,
and the source says
use a snapshot which
we took on the previous step.
So let's do that rollback.
So the rollback will
take a little bit
longer because as a
rollback, as I understand it,
it's a complete, full
application rollback, including
its pods and everything because
metadata was also stored.
So as part of this
upgrade, we will again
switch back from UI version
2.0 to UI version 1.0.
So now you see that all
the pods are terminating.
So we need to wait until
they are all terminated
and they will be replaced
with the snapshot
version of these application.
So, UI is always behind.
So I need to do
something about that.
OK, OK, OK.
Done.
So, the new version
is terminated.
And now you'll
see that the older
one, the snapshotted
version, will actually
start spinning up.
And here.
OK, so please know that
now UI is version 1.0.
So it's a previous
version of our UI.
And soon, we're going to have
all the pods running and ready.
And so we can go
back to the database
and see what's in there.
OK, let's take a
look at the database.
You see now we have
only one table.
And all our information is
back, so including emails.
So now we can fix the
upgrade and run it again.
So this concludes
our first use case.
And the second use case
is going to be migrating
our stateful workflow from
on-premise Kubernetes cluster
to GKE.
So, as a first step,
we need to actually--
now we have this local snapshot
we took before the upgrade.
Now we need to actually
make this snapshot
available for the
external cluster.
To do that, we actually
export this snapshot
to include in data and metadata
to GCS using this script.
So we are creating
application backup
as a source to provide a
snapshot, which we took
in one of the previous steps.
And the target location
we say is the GCS bucket.
And the secret we provide
to give controller access
to the bucket.
So let's run the script.
Usually, taking backups may
take time because it's like--
we transfer data from local
storage to the remote one.
But, in our case, we
don't have a lot of data.
And usually our
storage providers--
they support incremental
backups, which means,
once you upload it-- like,
full backup, the next updates
to the backup will
be just incremental,
so only the deltas will be sent.
So, done.
So, OK.
The backup was exported.
And we have this backup
ID which we'll need later
to actually import information
about the backup on the GKE
cluster.
OK, let's switch to GKE.
I'm going to switch the
kubectl context to GKE.
Done.
Let's take a look what we
have in the GKE cluster.
Nothing.
That's good.
Exactly what we need.
And, yeah.
So the first step, now
when we are in GKE cluster,
we want to import knowledge
about the external backup
to internal Kubernetes cluster.
So for that, we'll
need the ID I was--
actually, let's take a look
first at the import script.
So as you see, we
are going to create
the application backup, which
refers to the external handle.
It's the ID we obtained
in the previous step
when we exported the backup.
And as a location for
where we take the data,
it's GCS bucket, which is the
same as from the previous step.
So let's copy the ID from
here from the on-prem.
And let's go to the
cloud and run the script.
OK, so now we see
that information
about the external
backup was imported
successfully and pretty fast.
The reason that it's so fast
because we don't actually
import data.
We import only knowledge
about the backup.
And on the next
step, you're going
to actually rehydrate
the stateful application
from the backup.
So I'm going to run this
script, which will create
the stateful application.
And I specify the source.
I specify a backup, which this
cluster already knows about,
and just say create this
stateful application on top
of that based on that.
OK.
Oh, so now we see that
application is being imported.
And we can notice that
it's UI version 1.0.
It's the same one we
used for the snapshot.
And yeah, let's wait for
the actual application
to become ready.
Yeah, my GKE cluster
is behind firewall.
So I don't have direct access
to nodes of the GKE cluster.
So for that reason,
I'm going to need
to do some SSH a
forwarding-- port forwarding.
I'm going to use this
node port to forward it
to my local machine.
It's not going.
Wait, hold on a second.
I think it's here.
OK.
Yeah, so, basically,
I forward this port,
which would take the previous
step to the local port, 20090.
OK, it's done.
And let's go back to
the cloud and see.
OK, so imported.
So application's up and running.
Let's take a look at the data.
So it was port--
different port.
OK, something's there.
I'm going to use cloud
and select from customers.
Yeah, unfortunately
there is some issue
with networking and GKE.
I saw it previously.
But I know how to fix it.
So that's the good news.
We just need to bounce a
UI and it's going to work.
So I have a script
here, which just
says restart cloud demo UIs.
So what I'm doing here is just
basically bouncing the demo app
UI.
AUDIENCE: When are you going
to drop the new [INAUDIBLE]??
OLEKSIY STASHOK:
It's also possible.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLEKSIY STASHOK: OK.
Yeah, let's now see it again.
Come on, come on, come on.
OK, let's try it one more time.
And there is another
cure to that.
It's not talk to the service,
but talk to the pod directly.
So I'm not going to show how
you need to fix that in GKE.
OK, so, yeah.
So, it just--
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
Intermittent
networking problems.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Yeah, real sorry.
Yeah, that was--
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
So, yeah.
Sometimes, it didn't work when
I was at home doing the demo.
So I'm not surprised
it doesn't work
before such a large audience.
So it's kind of expected.
AUDIENCE: What are
you looking at?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
OLEKSIY STASHOK: Yes
that's a good point.
I forgot about--
MANU BATRA: I agree with that.
[LAUGHTER]
OLEKSIY STASHOK: OK, yeah.
Thank you.
MANU BATRA: Perfect.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]